en france pas d' équipes qualifiées pour
ce mondial mais une mobilisation chez
les policiers la grande peur des
hooligans britannique provoque la mise
en place de tout un dispositif entre les
côtes de la manche et la frontière
italienne ne cellule de crise au
ministère de l'intérieur on a prévu
aussi un contact permanent entre
policiers anglais français et italiens
c'est ce week-end que les supporters
anglais doivent traverser notre pays
l'angleterre je tournais fait son
premier match lundi prochain en
sardaigne au reportage
fr3 lille cécile canal écossais
irlandais et surtout anglais ce sont les
plus virulents d'ici à lundi ils seront
deux à trois mille supporters au
débarquement des ferries de boulogne et
calais c'est fou du foot en partance
pour l'italie et qui transite par le pas
de calais sont attendus de pied ferme
les postes de contrôle de la douane et
de la police de l'air et des frontières
ont été renforcés
à cela vient s'ajouter la présence
dissuasive d'une compagnie de crs 75
hommes qui assurent plusieurs vacations
de surveillance par jour
il s'agit pour nous en fait de faire en
sorte que ces gens-là stationne le moins
longtemps possible sur l'international
alors pour cela nous avons organisé
l'espèce de suivi les déplacements les
renseignements que nous obtenons sur le
nombre de supporters traversant les
frontières sur l'ambiance
l'état d'esprit nous les communiquerons
à nos collègues des autres services de
police de gendarmerie sur
l'international et naturellement nos
collègues des frontières voisine avec
l'italie le fauteur de trouble c'est
l'alcool les compagnies de ferries ne
peuvent pas en supprimer la vente sur
leur bateau sous le seul prétexte de la
présence de supporters d'autre part les
policiers savent que ce qu'ils ont
réellement l'intention de s'enivrer
s'approvisionnent en alcool avant
l'embarquement
ces dernières années il n'y a pas
vraiment eu d'incident grave lors des
transits de passionnés de vol par le pas
de calais il est vrai que tous les
passagers ne sont pas des supporters et
que tous les supporters ne sont pas des
hooligans